the relief was clear clear of kovat 19
and out of quarantine repatriated from
Wuhan fir'd their safety then isolated
to protect the UK from any spread of the
virus 83 of them now released we're very
grateful to have been here you know the
last thing that any one of us would have
wanted is is to have passed that virus
on if we were infected to pass it on to
somebody else
you know you have to live with that you
know if somebody does get sick from it
and and and and dies
we'd have to live with that for
knowledge for the rest of our lives
teacher Khan Lambert filmed his
departure he's been living in Wuhan
since 2014 but his grandmother was
visiting she's here in the red coat so
he chose to bring her home on the
evacuation flight and had to make the
difficult decision to leave his Chinese
girlfriend behind obviously it's tough
you know if it wasn't for my grandmother
being in Wuhan my massive worry and my
biggest worry was her you know so I
wanted to try and get her out of there
as quick as I could
if she wasn't there I probably would
have stayed and or I wouldn't have got
the first flight I might have got the
second flight you know with the
situation changing and the advice from
the government changing in that week but
it's you know obviously it's awful you
know I wish I didn't have to leave and
stuff but we talk every day so it's you
know that's nice we've had the odd
glimpse of the pressures being felt
inside here news of one patient who
threatened to leave at the weekend
prompted the government to introduce new
powers and medical experts are now
warning people leaving quarantine may
need ongoing help to adjust to what
happens next in terms of the risk of
coronavirus they're going about their
lives like anybody else however there is
a humanitarian issue to making sure
these people have got the support to
settle back into lives in the UK good
for now a normality of sorts but as the
number of lives claimed by this virus
continues to rise back home in Wuhan the
worry grows here with little idea
when they can return Sally Lockwood Sky
News the world